welcome to the pretty intense podcast I
have back on the show The ever so
popular Dr Stephen Greer Stephen was an
ER doctor that has turned into a
researcher of all things UFO
extraterrestrial he has amazing films of
which I've watched unacknowledged I
watched many years ago Close Encounters
of the fifth kind came after that seen
that as well and he has another one
coming out called the Lost Century about
basically like everything that we have
not known or has been hidden from us and
technologies that we should have in our
reality that we don't
um but of course this episode if
anybody's paid attention to my podcast
you maybe have come across this first
episode his first interview with me a
few years ago again very popular and we
talked about of course extraterrestrials
the government and programs this is just
a deeper dive into that and it was all
very much bond from you know everything
that's gone on recently with the
balloons being shot down and perhaps
crafts and what's going on so Stephen is
a wealth of knowledge he's been at this
for many many decades and he just has a
mission to well it's the last question I
ask him we'll have to watch you'll have
to see what is the what is Steven's
Mission because he really puts himself
out there and he puts himself in
potential danger he has a real passion
for it and he'll be at the national
Press Club again of which he hasn't been
there for quite some time and it was a
big deal the first time and he says he
has even more whistleblowers this year
so um very exciting so please enjoy the
episode uh click subscribe
um hit the like button let me know in
the comments what you think um it's
always fascinating to hear other stories
about perhaps what have you seen or if
there are people that have had
interactions with the government like
come forward he will protect you and you
can you know get your story out there
and let's get let's all get a little
enlightened
enjoy the episode
we meet again where are you right now I
am in Washington DC if I look that way
I'll see the White House in the
Washington Monument so um I'm here at my
place in Washington so you have a place
there or you're working there right now
I have a home here and a home out there
University of Virginia here in the Blue
Ridge Mountains so Farm out there but um
I come here about you know third of the
time for meetings with the work we're
doing
um that are we can talk about and it's a
lot of exciting things that have
happened since we uh last spoke
oh I know
everything is
funny lately like balloons are they spy
are they weather balloons are they
are they anything were there craft like
what on Earth has been going on the last
few weeks
so really what's been going on it
started with the Chinese balloon it was
obviously a spy balloon we shot it down
and the discussion uh or not then there
were the three other objects and events
um that appeared in the subsequent weeks
after that those were most likely uh
just civilian drones balloons or perhaps
something we had that was classified
they were not extraterrestrial Vehicles
Etc and so on now the part of it that's
very suspicious
is that all of that happened within
about a week of me escorting the first
top secret witness into DC to provide
testimony about what he knows about this
issue
um through the new wall that was passed
and signed just before Christmas of 2022
that allows top secret people to come
forward and speak about this issue even
though they have non-disclosure
agreements and top secret clearances so
this is something we've been working on
and advocating for for a long time it's
now enshrined in law and there's a
mechanism for these people to come
forward and one of the narratives that
people need to remember is that people
such as the co-chair of the Senate
intelligence committee Marco Rubio has
been gaslit by a number of
counterintelligence and disinformation
people who have been telling him all the
UFOs and uaps or maybe they're from
China so all of a sudden we're providing
clear evidence that these are real some
are extraterrestrial some are man-made
very classified illegal anti-gravity
propulsion systems that have been funded
through deep black funds and companies
like my uncle's company my uncle helped
design the lunar module his company was
Northrop Grumman huge Aerospace company
so I think that part of that whole
operation was a sort of a psyop
psychological warfare op and of course
the media lapped it up there were no
experts that got on that provided any
insight into this and uh the you know
hysteria and the public hysteria and the
media I think was a very calculated move
uh one of the things we've worried about
for years Danica is that at a certain
time when all this begins to come out
which is beginning to they could stay
some sort of threat from outer space
false flag operation and it sure as heck
look like a warm-up for that uh in the
past months I mean what is the potential
I feel like I mean I obviously don't run
in the same circles that you do into
that to that depth I'm just like
high-level curiosity but definitely from
like a spiritual Community perspective
there's definitely been a lot of people
that have talked about the fact that a
false flag is probably
what we're preparing for and what would
so why would they be doing a false flag
and what would the role of that be when
I heard there was those green lights I
think over Hawaii I was like oh man
drones could do that at night so easily
um so yeah to talk about the talk about
the potential of a false flag and what
they would do and why well this this
takes us back to the 50s so I have a cie
document that I got after I briefed uh
the director of the CIA on this issue in
December of 1993 so we're going back
almost 30 years
and I got a cash a box of documents from
the agency and one of them was
describing the psychological warfare
value of the UFO issue uh and it was
signed by the director of the CIA at the
time Walter Bedell Smith and it was
dated in 1953 before even I was born
never mind you so
um I was born in 55. so interestingly
what we see with this is a a 70 plus
year long-term strategy on this issue
and of course as you know the guy who
invented the rocket for Adolf Hitler
Werner Von Brown and his deathbed told
his senior assistant Carol rosin who's
on my team who's now in her late 70s
that in fact this entire threat of an
alien invasion was always in the cards
starting in the 50s that they began to
hoax things and position this whole
issue Into The Lunatic Fringe of
abductions and mutilations and War of
the Worlds and the movie Independence
Day and all this crap excuse me language
but and of course this was all you know
sort of script that out of cie covert
Central programs as a as an operation so
in reality I tell people that what we're
beginning to see ramped up
and it began after our documentary which
I know you've seen unacknowledged hit
about 760 million views worldwide wow
and when it hit that number up in that
three quarters of a billion range they
pulled the trigger on a
counter-intelligence operation uh headed
up by Louise Elizondo and a few other
people who were masters of
disinformation at the Pentagon
when they roped in this young guy that I
had briefed and and mentored for a while
Tom the long and Tom Delong was the
Blink 182 guy you know and he got he got
brought in there as a front man and this
whole thing came out the the ttsa group
to the Stars Academy and they started
saying yes these are real but they're a
threat to the National Security and we
really don't know what they are well
both of those are big lies we do know
what they are and they're not a threat
to the National Security
except the ones that are ours now here's
the punch line okay the ones that are
the UFOs that are man-made and that's
about 70 80 percent of the ones people
see okay are in fact a threat to the
National Security because they were
they're sort of a covert program that
can be used in a false flag just what
we're talking about and they have been
it can be used to Stage you know fake
abductions and mutilations and all kinds
of scary stuff now to what end I mean
you asked this question they want to be
able to unite the world around a sort of
totalitarian militaristic group yeah
which you know you can't do that by just
fighting a few Al-Qaeda people or one
country against another the ultimate way
to do that is you as Ronald Reagan said
when he gave his talk to the United
Nations wouldn't our job of creating uh
unity and uniting the world be easier if
we had a common alien threat to fight
I'm quoting I've seen I've seen him say
that wouldn't we come together if we
knew that there was another entity out
there how how much would we wouldn't we
unite in that exactly but instead of
coming together in peace and common
humanity and Enlightenment and higher
Consciousness and everything else we
come together around fear and militarism
this is like the one world government
that is like possibly coming down the
pipeline or that already exists I mean
the group that is running this is a
transnational
meaning it's not just in the United
States it crosses to your political
boundaries so when I go up and meet with
top secret people here in Washington
which I've been doing a great deal of
lately the first thing I tell them is
look at a map of the world
erase all the geopolitical lines they
don't exist for the group we're dealing
with it's transnational not
International and they operate with
alacrity all over the world uh and they
have enormous amounts of funding we
estimate that just out of the U.S
Hoover programs over the decades it's
around eight to ten trillion dollars
have been taken and spent on these
programs uh so it's a huge issue and a
big problem from many levels because not
least of which is not only is it the
future of how we view ourselves in the
universe and and whether we become a
civilization on an extinction level path
of endless war but remember that the
Technologies and go back and look at the
CNN footage
of our Navy uh F-18 Hornets chasing that
what they call the Tic Tac off the coast
of California
that white tic-tac-looking thing well by
the way that was made by the Lockheed
Skunk Works I know people who've been at
present when it's been loaded on C-130
cargo planes it's ours it's anti-gravity
what does it mean it's an
electromagnetic field propulsion and if
that were acknowledged it would be the
end of oil gas Co nuclear power solar
wind geothermal all of it so uh now
people need to understand what a big
statement that is it means that we have
about a hundred years where we haven't
needed to destroy the biosphere or had
half the world in poverty but the power
around the Petro dollar system from
after World War II Bretton Woods the
power around all those Commodities and
all the corporate structures your public
utilities
all of that is something we don't need
frankly actually we're going to have a
movie a full-length feature film coming
out soon called The Lost Century
how to how to regain it uh the subtitles
how to regain it and we just finished it
we hope it comes out June July this year
and it's going to be a two hour feature
film it's going to pull the curtain back
on all of this to the public so it seems
like this might be a silly question but
it seems like there's so many people
that are potentially getting quite old
that are part of this
control group
does that
bode well for us that the powers will be
transitioning that or or will it not or
or or do we need to worry about someone
like a Elon Musk or you know who is it
that it is that we need to worry about
and do you think that the transition is
happening into something else because
it's been going on for essentially like
a generation
it's been going on for uh about four
generations so uh in reality it's gone
through multiple levels of evolution
the big question in my mind since now
there's a pathway for the disclosure of
all this to begin to happen in Earnest
officially now my project called the
disclosure project which started as
project Starlight in the 90s when we
were doing briefings for the Clinton
Administration and members of Congress
quietly and I'm a you know emergency
doctor and I would fly up from my
hospital in North Carolina and do these
meetings in Washington it was a crazy
life you know with four little children
have four daughters one of the things
that I I discovered in that process is
that the president United States at the
time was not briefed on this neither was
his CI director members of the Senate
intelligence committee and other and
chairman of key committees like the
government over house oversight
committee that oversees the government
he came to a briefing I did he said I
have never been able to get an answer on
this this is deep black and these are
people who are have top secret
appearances in the U.S government I then
ended up briefing the head of
intelligence for The Joint Chiefs of
Staff Admiral Tom Wilson
J2 it's called J2 and he puts you know
he's in charge with the intelligence
briefings for the whole Joint Chiefs of
Staff and it was at the Pentagon and he
clearly said you know he was not only
not allowed into the projects he knew
they existed but he was threatened for
asking about them he was threatened with
the motion and and worse so I think one
of the problems is there's an
unconstitutional criminal operation
there's no other there's no way to put
lipstick on that pig uh that has gotten
out of control since the 50s I think I
think Eisenhower on his watch no fault
of his own had was outmaneuvered and
this covert group escaped constitutional
oversight by the president so is there
just one main group
uh if they're you know we are with uh
let's call them
ancillary support and because it's very
compartmentalized I know people who
worked on very high little projects and
they won't know what the person in the
next cubicle is working on it's TS SCI
top secret special compartmented
information and that's all done all the
time but this one is one that's deep
black instead of black now for example I
met with people who manage the black
budget of the United States but they
were denied access to the UFO UAP
extraterrestrial issue but they knew it
was going on you know the mainstream
media doesn't want to touch this it's
the third rail of uh politics and and
what have you but also the economy the
children of Earth are living on a planet
that is headed towards sort of an
extinction level event environmentally
and also in terms of War when it's
completely unnecessary so as an
emergency doctor I always joke I know an
emergency when I damn well see one and
this is an emergency and we need to move
on we need to get this resolved and
bring the all this information and
Technologies out and by the way we need
to have enlightened people making
contact with these civilizations and not
a bunch of sociopaths and and criminals
what is it that the that this group
wants to put into effect that they're
going to use the mechanism of fear for
because as you said if there's a false
flag it's to bring people together but
not in unity and Love and Hope and
joining hands it's a fear-based coming
together so you know with the mechanism
of fear what is it that they want to
implement it's about power and Global
power at a large scale I mean everyone
knows as a matter of public record now
even mainstream media PBS
CBS 60 Minutes have reported that uh the
Vice President Dick Cheney fabricated
um false information about Saddam
Hussein having weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq that justified us
going in and to Iraq and invading Iraq
after 9 11. it turns out that Colin
Powell who had been chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and at that time
was secretary of state was completely
gas lit by the intelligence operation In
The West Wing by Dick Cheney not by W
not by George W bush and he was sent up
to the United Nations holding up vials
of yellow cake uranium saying this is
what Saddam Hussein has he's a threat to
our national security it's all come out
now that was all fabricated out of thin
air and so we have trillions of dollars
spent hundreds of thousands of people
dead over a concocted so you don't have
to go back to ancient history to see how
this happened so I tell people
unfortunately people don't follow these
things very well I mean it's not like
it's sort of hidden in plain sight
there'll be a little bit of news
reporting and advantages and the next
thing anyone cares about is you know Kim
Kardashian's bra size or whatever it is
is you know important excuse me for my
sarcasm but um they want to know how she
lost weight that's totally what they
want to know these days yeah yeah
exactly I mean
deep underneath this it's really a story
of uh Power but also what the power of
this behind uh new science and
technology is imagine if you had a
device that would fit on
that table where you are that would run
your house or even a small pack that
would run your car never have to be
plugged into the grid so all Tesla cars
for example which are fake a real Tesla
would not have to be plugged in you know
if you're plugging it into the Grid it's
it's it's not a real Tesla Tesla
actually had a technology where he had
an electric car running without it being
plugged in pulling energy out of the
electromagnetic field around it so I
think that this is the sort of thing
where you go well you know JP Morgan
told Tesla if we can't put a meter on it
we don't want it to come out that's
right well this what was true in the 20s
is true 100 years later in 2023. so the
more things change the more they stayed
the same and so I think that you know
we're talking about something that would
Liberate the planet from poverty and
pollution and all this but it would also
this centralized power that has evolved
from the big Industrial
interest in the 1800s and 1900s that
would dissipate because in every village
every town every individual would be
self-sufficient
and these are called just so people have
the scientific name Quantum vacuum or
Zero Point Energy uh systems and they're
electromagnetic field systems aren't
going to put everyone to sleep with the
physics of it but we know what the
physics uh is and in fact uh Dr uh
casanir proved the zero point field in
19 in the 1950s so you know I mean about
the time you know I was born and you
know I think that this is why people
this is why this next documentary
is going to actually document from the
early 1900s to now what do we have in
these covert programs who's kept them
secret and why uh and that's what's
going to be in the Lost century and I
hope you can come to the premiere when
we get the date fixed yeah that would be
I'm sure it'd be just as awesome as
every other film that you've made what
are you most afraid of right now I don't
have personal fear although I've
certainly been threatened you know with
what you do there's always a risk for
the sort of things that you talk about
and expose but but within the realm of
shifts within the world what is it that
you are the most afraid will come
through or come to fruition
I think my biggest fear is the extent to
which the public and the media can be
manipulated like we saw in the last
month they're on much higher scale
similar to what happened I know this
controversial during covet where now
even the World Health Organization has
said the lockdowns were
counterproductive et cetera and so on
and as a doctor every doctor I know knew
that in March of 2020. I don't know a
single well except some idiot
bureaucrats in the government but but on
honestly every clinical smart doctor I
know knew that
um they know science they know clinical
medicine but so you see how easy it is
to pull the trigger on something get all
the media lined up around a narrative
gas like the entire population but with
huge consequences you know it's
estimated that about 10 times as many
people globally died from the lockdowns
from Disease and lack of Access to
Health Care and and famine then who died
from the virus so you have to ask the
question uh you know how how easy it is
to sort of manipulate people unless as
Eisenhower said there is an informed and
awake citizen rate which would be us
that's you know Ordinary People I'm not
in government I mean I know everyone a
lot of people but I'm not in that I'm
Not Elected I'm not appointed I'm a
private citizen however that is so I'm
really worried that a man who came to me
in the mid 90s
um who had been on an interagency deep
Black Project group he says he says I
was on a committee in 1974.
so almost 50 years ago where we could
push a button the skies would be filled
with all kinds of these man-made UFOs
they could attack or do certain actions
wow and it and it would be you know it
would create such fear and he said
because the president and the Congress
don't know we have these assets they
would be stampeded into all kinds of
responses and so would the public and
the Press so when and if he was the only
man I had met with who had been in a top
secret operation like that I would have
discounted it but I've met many of them
who knew about this agenda and so that
is my biggest concern is that if the if
the public and the media aren't aware of
all this and the president and the
National Security Council are and most
of the Congress virtually all of them
then they could all be deceived in this
kind of operation so I think that's my
biggest concern and when I was on a I
was on a four-week trip and so recently
and all this nonsense broke
New York and I were texting back and
forth and I said Yep this is what we
predicted most people who look at my
materials from the 90s went wow you know
Dr Greer was saying that this is the
kind of Direction they're going to move
in in the future so my concern is that
as we move forward with a dispositive
disclosure on this and now the Congress
has got behind a pathway to do that that
they could actually push that button
um and and that's a very big concern of
mine
it sounds like there's a sector of
people that are uninformed and so a lot
of that everybody yeah so what are the
questions that you get when you do these
presidential briefings and everybody at
the top of their top of their group what
what what kind of questions are they
asking you like the ones you're asking
they don't know anything I mean
interestingly I mean it was I remember
meeting years ago back in the early
2000s with the member of the Senate
intelligence committee who ironically
was from the state of Nevada which is
where Area 51 Ellis Air Force spaces and
uh it's very funny how that meeting
happened I was put on one of those
little golf courts golf carts at
McCarran airport in Las Vegas and I was
we were I was moved in clandestinely to
what looked like a Janitor's Closet and
it ended up being a place where VIPs
could meet and the senator and his chief
of staff were in there and we have this
very extensive meeting about this and
you know he says look you know this is
my home state I'm on the Senate
intelligence committee I have a I've
heard these things but I have never been
briefed on it or read into it so now you
take that experience that I've had here
and all over the world with senior
government officials and they're really
I feel very compassionate for them
because everyone thinks oh you're the
president you're this General you're
this Cabinet member most of them don't
know anything the ones who have known
things
like vice president Cheney he was on
this Cobra deep black committee since
70s and 80s
um way back
and they're embedded in various places
in government but their job is to
actually turn to their colleagues let's
say you're a corrupt Senator or
congressman who knows about this because
you're part of a club it's like doctors
believe each other lawyers believe each
other NASCAR racers
um
but here's what happens they turn to
their peerage let's call it and say oh
none of this is true if it were true I
would know about it and I you know I've
been involved in all kinds of projects
and this is what they're trained to do
there's actually a facility on my way
out to Charlottesville Virginia where
Thomas Jefferson's house is you go by a
town called Culpepper Virginia and Out
in the Country there there's a place
simply called the farm and this is where
they take people to learn how to very
professionally and convincingly lie
deceive they could pass polygraphs but I
know people who've gone through the farm
and um it's a very effective training
program but diabolical in many ways not
for normal let's call it spycraft but
for folks doing this where they're
actually involved in a criminal and
illegal operation that nobody is
allowing the key people now remember in
the Constitution
if you do things that you know the
reason I'm saying these programs are
unconstitutional and and criminal is
that I can prove and afford a law from
all the people I briefed
that and it's not just our country
United Kingdom Australia Canada that if
you're at that level let's say you're
the head of the defense intelligence
agency Danica which is like the CIA for
the for the military it's the CIA
civilian defense intelligence agency is
for the whole military and I agree the
director the head guy at the DIA
he wasn't given that he told where the
washroom was on this issue and so I was
actually brought in to brief him at his
conference room and he went over this is
really kind of comical he went over to
his bookshelf
and he grabs a little uh like you get at
a toy store a little E.T doll he says
this is all I've ever gotten for my
inquiries through channels at the
defense intelligence agency someone just
was making fun of him
so I'm going yes I'm not surprised
that's happened because I prior to you
briefed all these other senior officials
who have been also denied access when in
93 when I met with the director of the
CIA and learned that he and the
president had been denied access that's
when I knew we were in big trouble so if
they don't know anything and if they're
not part of this deep black
overt group are they so bad is the
government so bad are they a different
level of it maybe like a just a one step
below can we trust the government oh
well I don't I think even the founding
fathers who say you never just trust the
government that's why we're supposed to
have the fourth estate the media and the
public and elections but the problem is
is if that if you can't blame people for
what they don't know or don't even know
the questions to ask so getting back to
your point
many of the things that people when I
meet with these sort of folks that what
they're asking is to be honest with you
they know less than someone who has
looked at the documentary unacknowledged
but you can still see for free on Amazon
Prime or Hulu or 2B or whatever because
they're so busy with a million other
pressing issues that this issue until it
gets put on their radar
and again and they keep someone says you
need to take a look at this yeah but
these people are very busy I mean you
know I mean it's it's very hard to get
them to focus on something that has been
deliberately relegated to the realm of
Coupes and conspiracy theory it's gonna
rise to the top of the rise of the top
of the to-do list though with everything
that's been going on lately it seems it
is it's beginning to get there and uh
now the problem is about a year ago I'll
say this I need to be careful what I'm
saying here in February of 2022 I was
contacted by an extremely senior person
who had been tasked with looking into
this
and this was someone who should have had
an all-access pass on everything black
budget and classified uh he's at that
level
and he said uh you know I know that
we're being deceived and now we now
realize that they have been chasing
their tails for a couple years
um since the first bill was passed
mandating that the government the
Pentagon report to Congress on this but
they've never gotten anything meaningful
so this guy turned to me he says can you
help us I said oh yeah what do you want
so we're in this secure facility
um you know a skiff is a secure
compartment of information facility
classified and you give up your cell
phone and it's electronically all this
stuff
um and I gave him everything so I'm
still what I'm doing right now
I have handed off about a four or five
terabyte hard drive that is a massive
intelligence collection that we have and
I in it I named every facility every
corporation where the gates are where
the deep underground bases are
Etc
and based on that in the last year
they've been able to hit Pay Dirt
they've been able to get in
uh but it's dangerous I mean it's it's
very dangerous I mean you know you know
we got put on the watch
group list which is the kill list were
the Men in Black just about to show up
are the Men in Black real
oh yeah they're just operatives I mean
they're just sort of and some of them
are sort of these weird
um kind of uh
quasi-drone operatives you know where
people need to remember that you know
most like the the one of the men I just
debriefed last spring was at Nellis on a
on a team retrieving uh both
extraterrestrial and man-made UFOs that
that will be in the E.T ones that we
electromagnetically directional energy
weapons hit down
are we doing that all the time well
we've documented 119 cases where these
objects have been targeted and downed
and that is going to be revealed it is
in the hard drive now here's some news
for your folks and you're invited to
come
on June 10th and 11th in Washington DC
we're going to hold a conference at the
JW Marriott between the White House and
the Congress about all of this and then
on the 12th of June Monday we're having
a massive National Press Club event
where this all of this is going to be
unveiled and we're going to turn it over
to the media and to the Congress and say
go get them and we are not the only
thing I'm redacting
are the personal names the top secret
guys and women who want to be kept
secret and their cell numbers and emails
and stuff but I have a number of them no
at the national Press Club because I
know you had that coming out party with
everybody you know what year was that
that was in 2001. so this will be
disclosure project 2.0 okay so so we
have we have about 10 times more
whistleblowers and evidence than we did
in 2001 and it's something that's
important that we do this and I'd like
to have a lot of folks like you there
with your podcast covering it yeah what
um and by the way I still need that
NASCAR trip oh yes I've never been in
one I grew up poor in the South we
couldn't afford to go to a race I've
always wanted to be in one of those cars
going around a track so girl we gotta
I'll be well first off I'll come and
I'll be your personal escort if the if
goes down
out of it
you got some Navy Seals that are going
to be there protecting us and yeah I
would imagine what do you say to people
because one of the things that you hear
so commonly from
you know people that like someone like
I'm coming to mind like Neil deGrasse
Tyson which I he's a very smart guy but
one of the things that he says is that
where is the evidence like where is the
evidence and all I'm thinking is I'm
like I don't know it's everywhere like
it's like the walls of the pyramids it's
in the video footage that you find and
so what do you say and what would be the
most critical pieces of evidence that
you would say that you would counter
that argument to well that's a Canard
and and I always say to people you're
either completely ignorant of the
subject and haven't studied it or you
were deliberately lying now I don't know
the man that you mentioned I do know
that someone who is similar to him his
predecessor Carl Sagan was on the
payroll the CIA to Gaslight people on
this I bet I know for a fact his two
closest friends are on my team
so and one of them had been best man at
his wedding so you know whether or not
that gentleman I don't know but all I
would say is there's a book called
disclosure that is 500 and some pages of
government documents cases radar cases
of these objects top secret military
Witnesses and their transcripts that
anyone who wants it can go and download
it right this instant there's a
follow-up book called unacknowledged
that went with the documentary on
acknowledged we have put online all
manner content but if someone isn't
going you know you you can lead someone
to a water you can't make them drink but
I think in some cases this is Will for
blindness and what I have found is like
I was debating one of these kind of
characters at Purdue University who was
a skeptic from NASA
and it was the aerospace engineering
department for Masters and PhD people
and and and their professors
and what was interesting this guy is a
professional debunker disinformation guy
uh I think he's retired now his name is
James oberg uh and it was out of NASA
Houston I Believe and um so we're going
to do this debate in front of this huge
Auditorium and we're having lunch
beforehand sort of in The Faculty area
he looks around when no one could hear
him and says to me you're finding the
truth don't give up don't ever give up
he gets something on stage and he and
the moderator totally against me at
debunking everything I have and attacks
me calls me everything from a mind
control expert getting all these top
secret guys to lie to a fabricator of
top secret documents even though they
have their official declassification
stamps on it basically called me every
ad hominem vicious name you can think in
front of 800 people now it didn't fool
anyone but you know he was paid to do
that that is his job
um and you know so when people are
irrationally close-minded I I'm a
skeptic the only reason I found out that
you know the whole UFO Zeitgeist of
alien abductions and mutilations I found
out I ended up meeting with people who
had been in these deep black projects
who are staging those events I'm very
skeptical about most of what's out there
if you just Google this subject it's
just an avalanche of nonsense uh but I
tell people yes we have endless numbers
of cases are you how many do you need I
mean you know I have multiple of what
I'm about to describe a case where for
example
in uh the 80s there was a Japan Airline
747 heavy cargo jet going from Paris to
Tokyo
and a huge extraterrestrial vehicle the
size of multi like a bigger than a
battleship appeared and was on the the
captain of the Japan Airlines 747 it was
on his radar it was on ground radar
civilian and it was on Military Radar
Radar military jets were scrambled a
whole report came out of this the head
guy at the FAA here in Washington
uh had received all the radar tapes and
all the Digital Data from that and he
ended up there was a meeting where the
CIA came in and says we're taking
everything this is never going to be
talked about and they tried to cover it
up but if you look at my YouTube channel
you'll look up John Callahan and when he
left the FAA he had kept the originals
of that event radar I have them in my
archive so here's the problem how many
cases do you need like that where there
are multiple corroborating data on this
object which was moving non-linearly
meaning it would be at two o'clock and
in one radar sweep would be 100 miles
away instantly almost like teleporting
across the skies now that sort of
evidence if I had one case like that
it'd be but we have dozens
I think there are several hundred of
these sort of radar and pilot cases so
who goes in to collect because there's
obviously been bodies crafts who
collects them is this part of the deep
black group or is this the government or
it who it who is going in
making sure that nobody sees this stuff
well it's a deep black group that's a
hybrid government private let's call it
um and so a man if one of our disclosure
project Witnesses who passed away a
couple years ago Sergeant Clifford Stone
in the 60s was on one of these stream
teams the cover for the team was an NBC
team which is nuclear biological and
chemical but they sometimes these guys
start out doing conventional cleanups
and retrievals and then they graduate to
other things like this so there's a man
that just surfaced in the last few
months who was in the 2000s more
recently on one of these teams and it
was run by a Delta Force group out of
the northern range of the Nellis range
where Nellis Air Force spaces and of
course further south is the so-called
Area 51 facility but they were Way North
and they would have there was a
helicopter base and the Hilo base would
deploy to areas to retrieve objects now
when he first was recruited it was to
recruit to retrieve like when there was
an accident with a helicopter or an
osprey or a military jet because there
are components on that that are
classified you know Technologies and
whatnot so and then suddenly he got
moved into another level
where he was then first retrieving the
man-made arbs alien reproduction
Vehicles which we're going to show a
dozen of them in this film and at the
Press Club we're gonna we're gonna
actually have drawings we have pictures
they're all going to be on the on the on
the screen people are going to go WTF so
this guy
began to get read into doing that for a
few of these then the thing that made
him want to leave the operation was they
had electronically stunned
uh I think it was about
100 foot diameter I have to look at my
notes uh extraterrestrial vehicle which
came down out way out in the Northern
Nevada test range and they were deployed
to retrieve it
and some things did not go well uh but
basically they were not able to acquire
that device
um the ET Technologies were pretty much
able to put sort of everyone in sort of
stasis it's hard to describe a sort of
Frozen
um but he did get to see two of the ets
a male and a female and we have drawn so
we're going to show all the drawings
we're going to show what the crap was
and then when he was trying to escape
from that program
the covert the black projects attempted
to threaten him with death but also they
tried to abduct him and he fought off
this little gray alien and he kicked it
and what looked like skin opened up and
there were all these integrated circuits
and wires it was a sort of a
robotic yeah but very sophisticated we
looked and but they move rather uh
robotically but 99.9 of the people say
oh it's a gray alien or it's a whatever
and those are made by I know the people
who make make those I know guys who've
designed them and worked on them so I
mean are some of the extraterrestrials
robots I mean it seems like if we like I
mean look what's happening in our world
right now and look at the look at Ai and
look at the robot situation and you know
I just watched a video of a robot
playing basketball and shooting
basketball right
um so it would make perfect sense if you
wanted to go explore corners of the
universe or the Galaxy at least that you
would go send a you'd go send a robot
you wouldn't send a biological human is
that what we're coming into
communication with most of the time or
are we with biological extraterrestrials
there are both but usually they're
biological but they do have that asset
let's follow that technology but
remember the entire spacecraft of an
extraterrestrial spacecraft is sort of
on a nano
bio Machine level where it's on a
nanomolecular level it's sort of
connected to the uh biological and
conscious let's say thought aspect of
their occupants by the way that's the
foundation of the other documentary yeah
I think when we first met uh Close
Encounters of the fifth kind where
people can learn to make contact because
you know you and I are talking on this
thing that's at the speed of light
but if you're from the Andromeda galaxy
like that ET that came to us in Joshua
Tree by the way we're going to be out
there in April if you want to come
um National Park uh and
that being was from the Andromeda so
that's two and a half million light
years it's out of our galaxy so at the
speed of light even if they could travel
to speed of light
and communicated in two and a half
million years to say hello dear how are
you this morning and another two and a
half million years the answer back from
their base their star system so we know
that their Technologies are bypassing
linear space
we understand quantum entanglement
really yet so you know maybe once we do
they do yes we do
we do what is it
yeah so the way to look at it is that
the ultimate entangled aspect is the
Consciousness field but that has you
have to kind of redo the whole cosmology
which I've done it's actually up on our
YouTube channel but this is getting so a
deep dive of stuff but good it's from
the uh the sort of
undifferentiated conscious field how
does all of that which is infinite and
and omnipresent how from that do we get
you know this glass of water well that's
known I mean that's something that in
The Vedas was described science has now
done experimentation with Consciousness
and thought that proves that it can
interface with a Quantum uh random
number generators for example like Dr
John at Princeton who who I knew before
he passed away so I think there's a
great deal of evidence and research on
this now what we what we don't might
have I know Elon Musk is trying to get
there with neurolink is a reliable way
where I can just think to this computer
and it inner it does what my thought is
all right people are doing things with
brain waves and all that stuff but
that's at the speed of light I'm talking
about the quanta of thought the speed of
thought and the Extraterrestrial
civilizations they have both the innate
ability let's call it telepathy and
remote viewing like the cie remote
viewing program where it's just
Consciousness connecting but they also
interestingly have what I call Cat and
Tac is they have technologies that
connect with consciousness
okay so you can have something where
your Consciousness is augmented by a
technology but also
augment the cup augment the glass
augment the craft is that what you're
saying yeah yes and actually make things
happen through thought but also your
ability to do so can be enhanced through
some of these Technologies because it's
your it's your perception of the
situation it's your viewing of it it's
you paying attention to it with your
Consciousness that creates it because
now non-locality has been proven that
like that nothing is here unless you
observe it like inanimate objects so
that is what it's Opera is operating at
that level
well and even the father of modern
quantum mechanics and over a particle
wave theory orange Urban Schrodinger
said in I think 1908 the total number of
mines in the universe is one it's a
singularity so I tell AI people the
actual Singularity you're looking for
you have it already you're conscious and
you're awake you just have to study the
science of Consciousness but see when
you're dealing with civilizations that
are Interstellar
there's no way that they could go from
one star system to another using linear
speed of light communication or travel
it's too far so now you're dealing with
technologies that are what are called
trans-dimensional physics and that has
been studied uh for decades in
classified projects I've been studying
it pretty much my whole life
well since I was 17 when I died I had a
near-death experience and I went wow you
know there's something more in the
cosmos so I started studying
Consciousness and meditation
before the doctor became a meditation
teacher and was this itinerant
meditation teacher going around the
world but um in my mispent youth but
it was fun what a great what a great
skill to have from an early age
probably pretty well into your into your
practice as a doctor as well oh we did I
can tell a lot of great stories I think
every doctor should go through a
meditation training program so that they
have not only the science they need but
the heart and the Consciousness
um because I had like I had a boy come
in
um well boy young man 26 and he uh he
came in with all the symptoms of the flu
and it was flu season and so the nurse
putting that on a regular medical room
and I was busy with a lot about he was
pretty sick so I went and saw him he had
two two little kids and his wife I
looked at him and I could see it's like
removed you know I could feel and see
you know how dogs can pick up things I'm
sort of like a giant dog if dogs weigh
230 pounds and and I literally saw that
he had a brain tumor
and he didn't have any all of his
symptoms were the flu fever chills uh
nausea vomiting
and I said
you know it's again I just saw it
and I turned to the nurse I said I want
to stat the CT scan of the head and she
she just got she was North Carolina
well honey he's only got the flu I loved
it I said just do it that was my monster
just do it you know so back then we
didn't have every you know
bean counter bureaucrat in the
government insurance companies looking
over your shoulder 24 7. I'm just order
it and get it yeah because this was back
in the 90s and so
he goes back and they call back with an
emergency callback
he's herniating his brain stem
what does that mean the tumor it was an
asteroid cytoma like a pancake over the
top of his brain but it had gotten big
enough with the swelling it was pushing
the brain stem down through the opening
at the base of the skull and it was
hitting the all the parts of the that
part of the brain that caused fever
nausea all the symptoms of the flu but
he didn't have the flu at all in 12
hours if I'd send him home with some flu
medicine he would have died in 12 hours
so I tell people I mean it's kind of a
bizarre story but that sort of thing
happens a lot once you
um become you know aware of the fact
that the Consciousness whereby you and I
and all humans and all ETS have is an
infinite field and so this is actually a
very exciting area of Science and should
have been uh but but you know but that's
also something that the intelligence
Community doesn't want people to know
right let's talk about that because you
know I feel like I feel like even this
there's just a general sort of thought
or belief that there's Technologies
being withheld for healing purposes so
you know coming from not only of course
what you're doing right now but your
medical background and all of the people
that you know what I mean what is it I
want to talk about the future right like
what could come along with healing what
could come along with energy and
anti-gravity all that kind of stuff but
let's start with healing are there
healing modalities for cancer and very
and and and tumors and
um you know medical conditions that are
life-threatening
100 yes and in fact I was at a
classified medical research facility in
El Paso years ago on the border of
Mexico I think the actual facility might
have tunneled down and was under under
Mexico
um and they had technologies that were
these very Advanced trans-dimensional
physics electromagnetic systems where
they could repair a severed spinal
column if say someone's paralyzed from
the you know and they had Technologies
where if you had a missing limb you know
people have phantom pain but if you
study it sounds very metaphysical but
there is what the mystics would call the
astral body your body of light well that
energy field is still there it's very
subtle
but they had technologies that could
attach to that and then regrow the limb
that was missing
so I mean as a doctor I went in there
and I went wow I mean you know because
I'm using the best I have access to as a
doctor at the time which is you know
kind of caveman era stuff when I think
about it but um
yeah yeah on the chest tubes you know
but it works I mean you know you can say
yes but God for medical like modern
medicine right now like even as it is it
saves a lot of lives but we could be so
much further along this is the point so
then then you just extrapolate this
across uh every other discipline you
know
um one of the whole last part of the
Lost century and actually there's a
website for the lostcenturyfilm.com
because we crowdfund all of our our
films we don't allow a corporation or a
media company to fund it because I don't
trust them you know what I'm saying he
he who has the gold rules you know
they're always going to want to take out
stuff nope I have final cut over there
this
um I have total control over what it
goes out but what happens is that
you'll see in this last segment the last
part of that film is a whole we we spent
a lot of money doing Motion Graphics
showing what the world would look like
after all this begins to come out in 50
years 100 years 200 years a thousand
years on and on because I predict that
within about 20 years of the disclosure
of these Sciences
we would have no poverty in the world
and no pollution the world would be
restored to a pristine State and because
most of the expense of everything is the
energy associated with digging it up out
of the ground manufacturing it shipping
it think of that at every stage of that
supply chain and what have you it's all
energy intensive and where's the energy
coming from oil gas coal about you know
90 percent we have a little bit of
renewable but it's almost trivial
um at this stage and it's never going to
be significant until we bring out these
high-tech classified Technologies but
unfortunately we estimate that there's
over 800 900 trillion dollars
in Assets in these old dinosaur era
smokestack commodities
and unfortunately that's a lot of power
and a lot of powerful interests so we're
we're kind of stuck you know we either
have to find a way to bring these
Technologies out and try to give a
softer Landing as possible to everyone
working in oil gas coal Public Utilities
because you're not going to need a power
company or transmission lines because
every single home and business and your
car will have its own electromagnetic
power plant
and this is not an urban myth by the way
this we will prove we have you'll get it
from the ground the ground will be your
uh you're getting it from the fabric of
space time so think of it this way with
the ground right Tesla was from the
magnetic field yes some of his now he
back then he didn't quite know he knew
the effect with a very high voltage
system
um and I think a lot of Faraday in the
late 1800s others I'm not sure they
quite understood the physics of it
because it hadn't been elucidated uh it
is understood now frankly and and I
think that when the public understands
what's at stake here
I think whether you're a good old boy
like the guys I grew up with in North
Carolina with a pickup truck or you're
you know a policy walk concerned about
energy Supply or the environment or what
have you you're going to say well me if
this is true and it is then we need to
at least put some effort into an r d
effort one of one of the punch lines of
the film it's only showing the future
but showing the pathway to get there how
do we get from here to there I think we
here's what I think I think we need to
have an open source energy research lab
now you know you need 50 to 100 million
dollars in seed money but I mean in
Silicon Valley they put a billion
dollars in every kind of lame brain idea
every week
um they really do I mean it's you know
they're called unicorns
you know a new video to show your kitty
cat playing the piano or some other
frivolity but I know like commentary but
I think that really it would not be that
difficult I think in within about two
years of standing up an open source lab
open source means no patents no
intellectual property and I would have
the lab live streamed with blockchain
backup so that every breakthrough week
meet a whole lot of people with no egos
then
well you have to have people who care
about humanity and the Earth and Gaia
than about the almighty dollar
um and you know I think that's possible
they're philanthropic people out there
um I gave up my medical career to do
this what's the role of you had
mentioned it earlier and I just thought
of it because one of the questions I had
was about the moon what's the role of
NASA you know if we like lost the
technology speaking about technology and
you know open sourcing and letting
everyone contribute it's like what's the
role of NASA right now if you if you
were to take every agency and part of
the government there would be a very
small highly compartmented deep black
aspect of it so that does exist in that
all of them now that means 99 plus
percent of everyone that works for NASA
has no knowledge of it uh my uncle was
Northrop Grumman that had the contract
to build a lunar module that landed on
the moon the first time with Neil
Armstrong and uh as a little boy that
was a thing to be involved with but
um the reality is he was not read in to
this level at all because he was dealing
with jet thrusters and Rockets and all
that
um so I think that you know the best way
to describe it is I have a very good
friend who used to work for a JPL she
had proportional labs in California and
he Dr Richard Haynes and uh he worked
with me in the 90s on a lot of this and
he said yeah NASA we call it white
collar welfare reasons because we know
we're not doing anything I mean those of
us who understand this subject
you know we're making nice salaries and
we're doing make-believe whatever and
we're putting uniforms and the helmets
but what yeah we're putting you know I
told someone that you know the SpaceX
with Elon Musk yeah I said Rockets were
really cool in the 40s and 50s
but right now it's like really come on
dude
um but I mean he doesn't want to touch
this because I think he thinks you know
he'd be assassinated why did we lose the
technology to go to the Moon we didn't
lose the technology it just the ones
that were these anti-grab devices
um they never wanted the public to know
the traditional rocket systems
um and going there into that put the guy
Bosh on that after the landing because
when we landed there were other assets
there what was there if you look if you
read the unacknowledged book that goes
with the documentary you'll see there's
a testimony from a great guy named Carl
wolf he was out here at Langley Air
Force Base at a National Security Agency
highly compartment in operation where he
saw in 1968 the early digital downloads
of what was called the lunar orbiter
that was going around the Moon mapping
the moons we'd know where to land in
1969 and in some of those images were
ancient
structures
and also there were some newer ones
structures this is 1968. this is on the
dark side of the moon is this the side
that we don't ever see it was in the
area between where the the the where the
light that we see and the dark that area
uh as the moon hurts the moon spins but
it's just the way it's with us we always
see that one side but my point is is
that uh when the Sun's shining on anyway
it's just the motion of the Moon and the
Earth and the Sun it was known that it
was likely we were going to have
something like that happen so when we
landed at the Landing site the
Tranquility see the crater above it was
quote unquote crowded with these UFOs
sitting there and I know this for a fact
Buzz Aldrin knows that Neil Armstrong
knew it I tried to get Neil to come Neil
Armstrong to come forward but he told
his one his one of his best friends was
worked with me and he says yes but he's
been told if he ever talks about that he
his wife his kids and his grandchildren
will be killed they'll wipe him out yep
so I said look I'm not going to force
the issue but I know what happened when
we landed I know what was there you know
how it got covered up how the signals
were intercepted and things erased from
the footage before the public would see
it through a relay based out of
Australia at any rate the the point I'm
making is that yes I mean so I think at
a certain point it was decided maybe we
shouldn't pee going back so they they
after a few more events
they sort of wound down that Moon
project initially we were going to build
a a base up there and do all kinds of
stuff now keep in mind
it wasn't just extraterrestrial assets
there were man-made
assets
from before from the ancient times no
from this covert group so remember let
me give your folk your listeners a date
October
1954 was the date we mastered what's
called gravity control these
electromagnetic field systems so one of
the things we're going to show in the
Lost century and at the national Press
Club the national Press Club event in
June may happen before the film's out I
the distributor's still trying to fix a
date but we're going to show that whole
film at the two-day conference before
the Press Club
on that Sunday evening it's going to be
the Washington DC premiere of this but
in it people are going to see the
testimony and the drawings and the and
the uh artist rendition of this Air Show
at Norton Air Force Base in 1988
where uh but we have someone who is in
there who and we have the transcript of
what he just saw and described that he
gave that were three of these man-made
circular UFOs I think one was about 25
30 feet one was 50 and one was 100 feet
and they were just floating about in a
hangar in a classified area man-made
human made 100 man-made made
oh it was clear they were being shown as
deep black classified aircraft
I mean that's what it was
um and so
and it was really a pitch to to certain
people uh to get more money for the
project but the man who saw this the
interior the components were from the
Mercury era meaning late 50s early 60s
and it they it had markings on it where
it clearly and they were told it had
been all throughout the solar system so
we're talking late 1950s early 1960s we
had electrograbidic anti-grav objects
that had gone out of the earth and
around the solar system if that
technology existed in the 50s which
seems like when everything started to
happen with interactions with
extraterrestrials and perhaps crafts and
reverse engineering things
did they do it that quick or was it or
is it how long did it take them to
create those okay again this this unpack
that for a minute we unpacked this in
the Lost Century this movie coming out
if you go all the way back to the late
mid to late 20s with t Townsend Brown
and the ikowski frost experiment in
England in Germany
there were very high voltage experiments
where when you put very high voltage
um
frequencies around certain crystalline
materials or certain
circuits the darn thing would lift and
this was well documented actually in a
physics journals back then in the late
20s if I call this the Lost Century it's
a whole Century of exotic really cool
science and
um that was being worked on and studied
eventually what was called the B field
b-i-e-f-i-e-l-d b-filled Brown effect
from T Townsend Brown and this other
scientist became a real area of research
now that went forward and then Adolf
Hitler his secret program we had the
atomic bomb he was working on these
electrogravidic man-made sort of
anti-gravity craft that would you know
kick the the stuffing out of our you
know Army air force during World War II
but he did not perfect that before the
war ended and so uh Senator John Warner
who is the Republican senator who passed
away last year his son John Warner IV I
met with and we've interviewed him
and he talks about how his grandfather
his mother's father Paul Mellon one of
the few billionaires in the world at the
end of World War II went over to Germany
got this disc now there was the
so-called Nazi Bell this is an actual
disc it was anti-gravity and uh
Alan Dulles who helped found the CIA and
and Paul Mellon and George S Pat went
over there secured it brought it back to
the United States at the end of World
War II in 1945.
um and then we had Operation Paperclip
where we brought over the most brilliant
Nazi scientists like Werner Von Brown
Hermann Oberst others now so the
research had been done 20s 30s 40s then
got greatly boosted let's say by the
Downing and study of the
Extraterrestrial vehicles of the 1940s
and 50s so you had two big Rivers
combined in terms of scientific research
very black very classified that then
resulted in this breakthrough where they
actually were able to control accurately
what they call gravity control and one
of these electromagnetic devices what
Hitler had was unstable and actually the
early ones that you see from the late
four 30s and 50s
and some of the old movies you'll see
this UFO and it looks like it's
fluttering like this
that's a that's a man-made one where
they hadn't gotten the control of it
mastered it was unstable yeah it wasn't
a stable uh flight system at that point
but where they got good gravity control
was October 54 by the late 50s we had
the man-made ones unfortunately they've
also been used in simulating ET events
with abductions and other things so the
the public not knowing what I just told
all of you guys are going to see
something like this and go oh the aliens
that I said yeah right
that's what that's one of my uncle's
companies classified objects or a
Lockheed Skunk Works object or Raytheon
triangle
okay so now we're to the 60s the three
crafts are on the moon
and we know what I'm just saying these
other craft gone all through the soil
what which ones were up on the moon yeah
I don't have enough information to know
whether those were hours or
extraterrestrial
it's quite possible when we landed on
the moon
there were et's who were there because
they were concerned that the Apollo
mission was a proxy for the Cold War and
the Soviet and American competition and
I think there's a policy out there
amongst these Advanced civilizations
that you don't go out into space unless
it's in a peaceful unified purpose you
don't do it for conquest and Military
purpose I think it's a major directive
from a from these civilizations which by
the way there are many many of them it's
not just one and so I think there is a
policy not to let a primitive
um violent civilizations such as ours
too far out there so I cannot tell you
that's us right I personally have not
seen the footage I know people who have
seen the footage of those objects that
were of when we landed
um but I don't know from the description
I can't tell you if it was one of our
man-made ones or an extraterrestrial
there are certain things you can tell an
extraterrestrial vehicle is seamless
even the light from it is unusual
because it's so pure a man-made one if
you close enough to it it's going to
have seams it's going to have rivets
it's going to have Parts the
interstellar ones do not because of how
they're manufactured which we're also
going to show in the movie we're going
to show actually how they bring from a
trans-dimensional
field of energy into 3D
it's like trans-dimensional 3D printing
but the whole craft it's this integrated
seamless object
and so are there suits their suits don't
have buttons and zippers they
materialize on and off I know you know
how that's done and they're very
interesting Technologies so if you know
what to look for sure you're not going
to be fooled but this is such a granular
level of information
um and so for most people who would
encounter a man-made UFO with Critters
that look like aliens they're going to
get tricked you know yeah sure because
we haven't seen any of it why
terrestrials interested in us
well I think there are two things uh one
they see the great promise of humanity
but they also see that we're in a really
big problem right now so if you look at
the modern era and this is not talked
about often and I won't emphasize this
if you look at the modern era of the UFO
issue it all started really in the 40s
and particularly when we detonated the
first atomic bomb why
Not only was that like a big red flag
going up over the planet saying wow
these gorillas are getting a little out
crazy here we're 98 identical to
gorillas and chimpanzees some of us more
than others speaking for myself what
I've learned is that everyone knows what
an electromagnetic pulse is from an
atomic bomb or nuclear bomb what people
don't hear about is that there is
another
electromagnetic burst that goes fast
from the speed of light it's called
longitudinal or scalar and that actually
tears the fabric of the universe and
it's not just localized to Earth it
actually disrupts communication and
let's say trans-dimensional travel
systems that are Interstellar so when
those went off it was a huge concern and
this is why all through the 40s 50s 60s
there was surveillance by these et's
over all of our missile sites nuclear
weapons story and it wasn't because
they're hostile now the way the media
has begun to spun this and the UFO Kooks
is that it's an alien invasion of our
nuclear silos I'm going get over
yourselves if they want to hit a button
and terminate all wife on this planet
they could do it instantly with what
they have technologically it was because
our Sciences have been misused for war
and when you cross the nuclear threshold
never mind Interstellar
trans-dimensional physics which are even
more potentially dangerous
if you haven't become socially and
spiritually a peaceful
Planet living together in peace you are
an existential threat to yourself and to
others now I always use that term
because as an emergency doctor someone
comes in
escorted by the police or family who are
as dangerous to themselves or others you
can commit them because they're they're
legally committable and insane or what
have you I think Humanity right now
as you is viewed unfortunately
collectively a bit insane that we've
allowed all these things to happen and
until we become what michikaku calls uh
a level one civilization where we're
peaceful not damaging the environment
level work well we're a level zero so
level one would be that now I've mapped
out what a level 10 is it's actually on
my YouTube channel it's really great oh
yeah it goes all the way up to level 10.
okay well what's level two yeah level we
wouldn't go through them so level two
one let's describe it yeah you you have
these Technologies out you're not
cannibalizing your environment and
poverty has been eliminated and you're
really peaceful because you don't have
anything to fight over level two is when
that's becomes stable enough
that that is a permanent piece it's not
something that's going to come and go
like we have these periods of peace and
then War it's a absolute permanent piece
and then a level three then you know you
get that the neck when you get to that
point you're cleared for Interstellar at
that point you can go out there
um and it keeps going up from there
based on the level of consciousness of
the planet in its aggregate so um
meaning the development of higher States
Of Consciousness which I link back to
the ancient Sanskrit Vedas and the
cosmology that I learned when I was a
young boy or a young man so uh but I
think that's where all these
civilizations are at least a level
most likely four to ten if you get on I
mean we don't have time to go through
all that but they're very Advanced
um and they're certainly not violent
because if they were hostile and were
intrinsically that unevolved they would
never have been allowed out of their
solar system
it's an absolute requirement really a
Galactic Federation
well I mean that's something you hear
about from you know spiritual people and
like people with psychic natures and you
know you really don't understand
and things like that and they'll talk
about the Galactic Federation there's an
organization that's Interstellar
Galactic remember that the galaxy is the
Milky Way and it's only one of hundreds
of billions of galaxies so it's an
incorrect term
um for example this ET Ambassador that
we took a photo of that appeared at
Joshua Tree a few years ago it was from
Andromeda so it's Intergalactic because
he was that's a two and a half million
light years from here it's the closest
galaxy to our Milky Way and our Milky
Way has whatever is 100 billion star
systems
and is estimated upwards of a billion
earth-like planets just in our own Milky
Way but there are billions and billions
of these galaxies
um and so I think that you have to
really look at this in a more
Cosmic way to get your mind around the
vastness of what we're dealing with now
not all the civilizations that exist in
the cosmos would be tasks dealing with
the civilization at our level a level
zero civilization that has not learned
to be you know civilized because we're
not I mean you know there's come to my
emergency department on a Saturday night
I'll prove it to you
um so you know so that there's an
evolutionary pathway as I see it and
we're sort of emerging we're sort of
half a step out of the Jungle we're
trying to emerge out of that but the
Hallmark of it is we're peaceful we're
not killing each other Wars have ended
we're not ruthlessly suppressing these
technologies that could uh eliminate
poverty and hunger and uh heal the
planet as well as individuals all that
has gotten resolved and that's that's
where we've been stuck for 100 years see
that should have happened about 100
years ago before
even my parents were born virtually so
um so I think that this is why I tell
people the only way you make a
transition this big is bringing people
together with knowledge and but also
with Enlightenment but also a vision of
where should we be going and how do we
get there
so we try to map that out at the end the
the last chapter of this this
documentary film The Lost Century but um
of course you know it's a lot of work to
do and unfortunately all of this should
have been resolved before I was born you
know so it's sort of like we're all kind
of stuck
um trying to resolve something that's
had this momentum in these deep black
projects uh and and how to unravel it
but the first step is at least educate
each other but also explain that go
ahead and like if you could outline
perhaps from your perspective or maybe
it's in the film
um or in the presentation or what's
going to happen in DC but what are those
next few steps
to getting to that point
I think we need to have an open
disclosure project right now what's
happening with the congress the people
coming in there and the once I'm
identifying or going into a skiff and
their testimony is classified it needs
to Pivot to an open
a transparent process which I'm hoping
that will get there
um in the meanwhile my group or the
disclosure project we're disclosing
everything we can uh because uh I have
top secret documents that haven't been
Declassified and I think about six dozen
of these Witnesses who are military and
corporate that we're putting out there
because they can go ahead and do it and
they can't prosecute us because we
declare those projects uh criminal
Enterprise in 1997. so and that's never
been rebuked it's never been uh
corrected we wrote a letter to all the
agencies and said here's our assessment
we're going forward but now there's an
official pathway which a lot of like the
gentleman I I about a month ago brought
here to Washington he had very high
clearances and he didn't want to say
anything until there was a clear pathway
sanctioned by the government for him to
testify now we have that that's a new
that's just in the past two months so
then the other thing I'm asking for we
need courageous men and women who have
been in these covert programs to come
forward as whistleblowers have them
contact me if they bring to you but you
can just contact me at info at
seriousdisclosure.com
s-i-r-i-u-s-disclosure.com which is my
website because if they contact me and
you know I'll keep their information
confidential very good at doing that as
a medical doctor and if they're willing
and if I think that their information
warrants it we will then arrange to
bring them to Washington here so that
process is ongoing and in fact I was on
a Navy SEAL podcast a couple weeks ago
called the uh the Sean Ryan Show it's
the vigilance Elite and it's had
millions of views and we've gotten
another half a dozen top secret
whistleblowers who've come forward just
from that so you know people looking at
your podcast or maybe people or someone
who knows someone and it's all about
networking this um but they need to know
we're going to keep them safe and we're
going to keep their names confidential
from the public unless they want to be
known not ultimately I wish people would
just all come forward with their names
everything but I understand people who
are afraid or people who don't want to
be in the public eye
um you know I certainly wish I hadn't
been uh pushed into the public eye on
this but
um ruin us to have that happen you know
but uh as you know but I think that some
people like it I don't like it but
um
I can't walk through an airport or go to
a Starbucks without being stopped but
and I don't like that frankly I mean I
like my privacy but my kids hate it more
but I think that my point is is that I
understand someone not wanting to come
forward publicly but the more we can do
this
uh publicly with their names and
information and in fact even at this
National Press Club event uh the better
but there's certainly this other
mechanism where they'll be kept very
confidential and the people I'm working
with here absolutely you can trust
they're wonderful guys what is it that
finally pushes this over the goal line
like what is it that will finally get
everyone to go there it is okay
undeniable
I don't know if it's a singular event I
think it's a process I mean basically
what we put out already should be that
but what people are waiting for is an
official assessment
and open disclosure of this by the
government and the media reporting it
whether or not we get to that or I don't
I I honestly here's what I thought when
I put all the What's called the best
available evidence together for the
president the CI director in 1993 before
I thought it would be over that the
president would do the right thing
at the time it was Bill Clinton
that they would dig into this and it
would be disclosed they'd start bringing
out these Technologies we'd have a new
world uh boy how naive I was as a
30-some-year-old medical doctor and you
know I mean in full disclosure I've
never worked for the government been in
the government worked for done any of
that I'm completely uh
civilian person interested in this I
have no official standing at all but
ironically the information we've
acquired in the last 33 years exceeds
anything that anyone in the
constitutional government has which is
why I feel obligated to turn it over
so warts and all I mean they're getting
an enormous tranche of intelligence one
I'd just be remiss to not add ask about
I'm so fascinated with Antarctica
is there like
extraterrestrial bases is there
something inside like underground what
is the role of Antarctica I basically
want to know if I need to plan a trip
and just put my MacGyver hat on and yeah
I can suggest better places to go that
are very close to where you live
um I've had some of those too South
mountains we had an ET craft come right
over us and we were hiking out there
last year
um but
um right thus came down
it was phenomenal so what are the hot
spots so before we get to Antarctica
then since you're saying you know some
other spots what are the hot spots on
the planet where the most amount of
extraterrestrial activity is most amount
of craft sightings
well I actually think they're wherever
you do the ce5 contact uh protocols
properly now everybody can get an app
it's called ce5 Contact it's a whole
training program in remote viewing the
protocols for making contact you
actually open up a a an interdimensional
Vector you have a group of people doing
that so what I've found if that if the
if the Consciousness in the group is
coherent the ET come no matter where you
are in some form or another now in terms
of routine activity there's a great deal
between Catalina Island and Malibu
because there's an ass a facility there
there are ones that are certainly are
out in the desert near near you
you go to parts of South America
they're a great deal seen happening up
in Peru and those those High Andes now I
think that there have been in our
extraterrestrial
facilities in many places in the center
of Joshua Tree National Park
in 96 I was took a group up there and we
didn't quite know where to go and we'd
gone to a place that just didn't feel
right and then suddenly I said let's
move my intuition and as we were leaving
there was about a 300 foot diameter
a green it was looks like a Hershey's
kiss with this green trail and it went
straight down like a rock
and lit up all the Joshua tree for just
a couple seconds and it it was partially
materialized and went in everyone saw
this and it went into the desert and I
noted where it went in my sort of
GPS that my brain looked and calculated
it and that's where we go to make
contact but we'll be there in April if
you want to come but that's a base I
think there's okay a base because when
you said went in it made me think is
Hollow Earth really a thing I don't know
that it's so much Hollow Earth but there
are certain places where ET uh
trans-dimensional
craft and can operate and have operated
historically uh way inside mount
shasta's one okay we've gone there many
times and had amazing you know these
sort of like luminous light ships or we
have videos of these coming out towards
us and then we have these amazing
contact events happen so
um yeah there are certain places but I
don't think it's dependent on that I
think that you remember given their
Technologies any point in space you know
time they can appear if you have a group
that's
synchronous coherent doing the
Consciousness part of this and are also
doing it for an altruistic what is your
intention if you're just there to be
entertained or not interested I mean ETS
are not going to be Dolphins at Sea
World for people I mean it's it's
humiliating uh but uh and my view of it
what I've experienced is when people
sincerely want to be part of a process
of humans uh being sort of ambassadors
from Earth to their civilization and
you're willing to be in service and help
as opposed to selfishly just being on a
trip then they come otherwise they're
not interested because they figure
you're an immature Soul not worth
bothering with so Antarctica
Antarctica anything yes I mean there are
a lot of covert human assets there that
are this type of craft now also at the
South Pole we just have a guy who worked
for Raytheon who for a year
raytheon's a big defense contractor and
about two miles under the ice is this
massive technological array which are
neutrino light detectors which is a type
of system that detects
um very subtle energy as a craft
materializes from trans-dimensional
space time into 3D there's an energy and
there are ones on satellites in space I
know the man who invented the one and
that's how we track these craft and then
triangulate them and hit them with an
electromagnetic weapon so that is huge
facility and it's at the South Pole and
Antarctica has other facilities so I'm
not so sure that it's Rich for
extraterrestrial activity but it's
certainly a very Dynamic area for covert
deep black human Okay operations yeah
okay how long in your opinion do you
think it will be before we have global
Collective Agreement on the existence of
extraterrestrials I would not wager a
bet I was betting in the 90s that it
would happen imminently
um you know when well we were originally
gonna originally going to do the whole
disclosure event at the United Nations
but then the Secretary General of the
Union was threatened and we had to move
it to the National Press Club that's a
very interesting story
and uh Paris you know it was uh uh after
I had met with boutroscali who was the
U.N Secretary General in the 90s uh his
his successor was also very supportive
and uh but they were they were sat down
pretty hard and said you will not do
this or you'll lose all your funding uh
so uh you know these guys play hardball
I mean it's a hard ball game
um so you know and that's you know
that's the School of Hard Knocks I went
through when I thought well you know as
a medical doctor and prior to that a
meditation teacher people would do the
right thing to save lives and help the
planet then I you know I hate to sound
cynical but I mean at this point I go
I'll believe it when I see it now it
doesn't mean we'd give up we have to
keep pushing that but I don't look all
if you look at you know I grew up 60s
early 70s in the South the Civil Rights
Movement didn't happen because the
Kennedys just one day woke up and
decided we're going to support this
it happened because
organizers like Martin Luther King and
the people got behind it a non-violent
movement that's what we have to do with
this issue both with contact with these
civilizations and I I was involved in
that I saw that happen same thing with
women's rights uh same thing with uh gay
rights all these things they didn't
happen because the muckety mucks in
Washington or Paris or any other place
did it they did it because we the people
led so I always tell people if the
people will lead the leaders will follow
I shift the focus not on the leaders in
Washington but on us we the people I'm
very much about we the people and I
think that once there's enough movement
of the people for this then the leaders
will have to follow it so that's why
we're doing that's one of the reasons
we're doing this National Press Club
there are senior people in Washington
actually I cannot name them who have
asked me to do that event
to get more public and social pressure
on the government to move forward that's
exciting all right well then the last
question I have is just Why do you keep
putting yourself out there this what
what is what is it what is the vision
you have because I think I have seen
what's at stake I mean I've seen the
world we're in and I've seen the world
it could be and when you see how amazing
this planet and Humanity could be if
some of these issues could get resolved
properly and non-violently
then you know this is the pearl of great
price this is the one you don't throw
back in my soul I know where we could be
where we can be and therefore if we work
hard per chance we'll get there but I
think it's a lot of hard work it's much
harder I mean it's an ultra ultra
marathon which when I was first starting
out doing this stuff in my 30s I thought
it'd be a slam dunk but you know
um you know you know looking 33 years
back I go well you know it's
you learn a lot one way or another
humanity is going to get on this uh path
where we're going to be sustainable
peaceful all these technologies will
help heal the planet poverty and disease
will be forgotten be a thing forgotten
and we'll become Interstellar so that I
see that that's where we're going to go
as an enlightened civilization therefore
if if you don't work for that I mean uh
right the way I justify I haven't left
my medical career is I kind of joke
I used to take care of all the car
wrecks and shootings and all that fun
stuff but uh now I think my our patient
is is the Earth and her 8 billion
children so that's our patient yeah yeah
well that's a pretty damn good reason
yeah thank you so much I do thank you
for sharing I'm excited about all your
new projects coming up and yeah there's
always going to be more to talk to you
about well we'll uh we'll send you some
links so people can figure out how to
come to this event in Washington and the
Washington premiere of the film and um
hope to see you there maybe you could do
a podcast from uh the national Press
Club that'd be pretty cool I would love
it would be cool all righty good to see
you soon thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today I
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe button